oh the hell is for I don't know I
couldn't really hear him it sounded like
his name is for it his number no good
girl Ron Swanson April Ludgate hey I'm
just gonna pop over to grain and simple
to get the very best ingredients for my
burger do you want to come
what is grain and simple it's health
food store Pawnee doesn't have a health
food store no but snarling does and it's
only a 40-minute drive
what are you doing Andy I'm getting
healthier snacks for the shoeshine stand
chris is a food genius did you know that
the food you eat becomes energy yeah
boom that's spaghetti nachos the cookie
that's my husband oh hey guys cambree
Annie no Johnny no I don't plan to buy
anything here I buy my burger and agree
dance at food and stuff a discount food
outlet equidistant from my home in my
work I came here for the same reason
people go to the zoo Shh look at that
thing
nature is amazing where's this dude
would you like to sample our vegan bacon
100% meatless yes please another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this I don't
think I can give you any more I want one
yeah what's this
dragon fruit what's this a Kawano or
horned melon what's this a peach I knew
that Wow fresh lettuce is my all-time
favorite food
what's your favorite food oh I take
skittles and I put it between two
starbursts you know what I call it
skittle sandwich that's pretty good
no I call it Andy's mouth surprise it's
nice because the the flavor of the
starbursts really bring out a similar
flavor in the skittles I think if you
continue cross-training the way you have
you're gonna I don't see any ingredients
have you bought ingredients nope
do you need help shopping no are you
hurt he moved I've never felt better
[Applause]
okay give these I said one thing honey
pinwheel
I love food and stuff it's where I buy
all of my food and most of my stuff hey
can I get these how much are they 2
bucks apiece
good deal anything else nope just the
crows and the beef
you